foreign
please
not forget the appointment book have a
good show
see
I feel anxious tell me about it well
we're making a film and I'm not an actor
well we're not expected to be actors
we're just supposed to do what we do
yeah that's what makes me anxious you
see we do sex counseling
and that involves talking about sex yes
I thought men talked about sex all the
time
well yeah they brag about it and they
tell dirty jokes
but they don't really talk about sexual
feelings
but they know all about sex
where do you think they learn
weren't they born knowing not any more
than any other kind of human being oh
well if they don't know
why can't they ask
well see a guy can't ask because he's
expected to know right if he asks then
it means he doesn't know so he doesn't
ask
I see well that's an awful bind to be in
I can see where that would make you
uptight not wanting to talk about sex
you know I got another problem
well you better tell me about that one
too well I'm a physician you know when
people go to their doctor and expect
them to know all about sex
see how are the people watching gonna
know we're doctors I mean are we
supposed to introduce ourselves I don't
know
and how do the people know that we're
doctors
don't worry about it no we'll just burn
it in
they're gonna
Bernadine
what does that mean
the faintest idea that's some kind of
professional jargon we're ready
pharmaceutical Corporation presents Bill
and Sue scene one take one a co-therapy
team approach to conjoint sex counseling
go ahead
do you want to start no I'm still
nervous
oh I think we've got some patience
outside would you like to see them yeah
I always feel more comfortable when I'm
with a patient good
what are you doing I'm Mrs Williams a
patient I'm a nurse and I've been
married for three weeks I see when you
put on that jacket and that purse then
you're Mrs Williams that's right
and I've got a problem I'm married to
you oh well when I put on this jacket
the in this pair of glasses then I'm Mr
Williams and I'm a retail clerk in a
clothing store right and I've got a
problem
oh I married to you and we've been
referred by our Minister for counseling
he's a pretty understanding fellow
where are we oh we're in the waiting
room waiting for our appointment
we are right
yes
I'll bring them in
you can often get a very accurate
impression on the patients you are going
to see simply by observing them as they
wait in the reception area we find it's
useful to conduct the patients in
personally it gives us time for this
first assessment and Begins the
establishment of rapport
we notice for instance that much useful
information can be gleaned from watching
how patients seat themselves and where
they sit relative to each other it's
very obvious at this point that the
Williams are both distressed his
constant scratching and her fumbling
with her hair purse reveal their
discomfort
two little things before we start
but first if it's all right with you
we'll use everybody's first name and
that gets away from the witch doctor's
witch problem
mine's no one
's burrow
I'm Sue and his name is Bill
yeah well like she says my name's bill
bill
and soon that's fine
now the second little thing we tape all
our sessions we do this so that we can
play back to you what you say if this is
helpful we don't keep the tapes we just
recycle them so if it's all right we'll
start the tape recorder I don't see
anything wrong with it
it's okay
okay let's go back to you Bill can you
tell us right now how you're feeling
fine yeah
and how about you Sue how are you
feeling right now
I I'm feeling pretty nervous
most people feel pretty uptight when we
begin Sue that's pretty normal
we find it very important to give the
patient permission to feel the way he's
feeling many people feel anxious when
they come to see the doctor for the
first time and especially in this type
of anxiety-provoking situation Bill who
said he is fine is obviously not fine in
our society men need to be given even
more permission than women before they
are able to safely divulge their
feelings bill can you tell us what you
consider the problem between the two of
you to be
oh boy
I feel
I still read tell me about it well I
mean I put out my hand and you rejected
it and I feel rejected
that's right well you know how I get
when you get sexy like that
I wasn't getting sexy I just needed some
comfort right then and I figured you did
too
well I guess I did but I was sore
because when he asked me my name you
answered for me like I didn't even know
my own name
oh
I'm sorry
well I guess I'm sorry too
Sue is that how you were feeling
yeah
that's where I put out my hand
Bill did you realize that's what she was
doing
no but what you said
yeah I get it now
we often mirror the actions of the
patients and then show them an effective
way of letting each other know how they
are really feeling mirroring and
modeling are useful tools to a
co-therapy team
there was an apparent misperception on
the part of the Williams I decided it
would be a useful time to pick up The
Feelings they had but were unable to
express to each other then I checked
with them if we had accurately expressed
their feelings it was important to each
of the Williams to receive support from
the therapist of their own sex
okay Bill the problem as you see it
well we've been going together for three
years before we got married well we had
lots of fun before we got married you
know fooling around and well you know
hey no right now this film is only so
long we can't do it to all the details
well okay we'll summarize
during their courtship soon Bill decided
that they would save sexual intercourse
until after marriage so they did
everything but including petting to
orgasm the problem began on the wedding
night when an early attempted
intercourse provoked pain ensue and Bill
became frightened and backed off the
rest of the two-week honeymoon was a
disaster they continued on their plan
motor trip but when they retired to the
motel room they renewed attempts at
intercourse the first two or three days
after Bill encountered Sue's repeated
distress any further attempted
intercourse was prevented by his loss of
erection this then became the focus of
their fear and concern they avoided
discussing sex and eventually even
stopped having any physical contact
Sue can you tell us what you consider
the problem to be
well I mean when I married him I thought
he was a a man
and knew about things
now I find he doesn't know anything
I feel threatened
tell me about it well it's this
expectation that I'd know all about sex
you mean men weren't born knowing that's
right
oh but I expected that my husband would
be in charge of that area
so you were pretty disappointed Sue
but it wasn't a realistic expectation
Sue can you tell us what happened on the
honeymoon
well I was real happy when we went to
the motel on the first night and well we
went to bed
and then it all happened so fast he
tried to put it in and it really hurt
and then he couldn't do it anymore
following the first part of the intake
session where the couple was seen
together each patient was then
interviewed separately by the therapist
of the same sex this is done not only to
obtain an adequate history and help in
the diagnosis but also as a therapeutic
measure during which feelings are
explored and information and reassurance
given this session usually opens with
history taking over a cup of coffee or
tea the intentions of the patients with
regard to their Partners is explored the
intactness or Eco strength of each
individual is assessed with relation to
their being able to continue with our
form of therapy
when we finish the individual interviews
the couple waits in the reception area
while we confer on what we found we see
if we can establish a diagnosis we also
compare their separate intentions with
regard to the relationship
well let's call them back in now right
well from what you people have told us
you've got a lot of things going for you
in your marriage many strengths
most importantly you want to put a lot
of work into your marriage
now let's take a look at some of the
problems
as you recall
on the night of your honeymoon
bill was pretty uptight
and without stopping to deal with Sue's
feelings he tried to insert the penis
on the first night Sue encountered pain
and on succeeding occasions fear of pain
which led in turn to increased
vaginismus
The increased pain on Sue's part brought
forth an impotence reaction on the part
of bill and his fear of failure led to
failure and more impotence
the fear of pain and fear of failure
resulted in an avoidance of each other
leading to loneliness
accusations withdrawal
and more avoidance both of each other
and a lack of sex play
each time the penis is inserted
without adequate sex play the pain of
vaginismus and the failure of impotence
will occur
we regularly employ flow diagrams in a
simple way these illustrate for the
patient our conception of the pathology
pathogenesis and possible therapy having
what they consider to be an immense
problem laid out on a green board in
less than five minutes allows the
patients to see the situation in
perspective and thereby reduces their
anxiety
at the end of the intake the Williams
were offered a series of four conjoint
sessions spread over roughly four weeks
with time in between to practice what
they learn at each session these
sessions are aimed at reducing anxiety
providing information concerning sexual
function and setting up a series of
tasks aimed at helping them to overcome
the fear of failure cycles in which they
are locked we encourage them to discuss
their feelings about the intake sessions
in general and our diagnosis in
particular before deciding to accept
this therapy
fine we'll see you then bye
that was Sue Williams the newlyweds we
saw yesterday they'd like to come back
and we can see them in about two weeks
okay
at the beginning of this session we were
pleased to learn that Bill and Sue had
accepted our earlier suggestion to
refrain from having sexual intercourse
by themselves they resumed the petting
they had enjoyed before they got married
with the result that they were again
bringing each other to orgasm
is there anything that concerns you now
yeah well what I want to ask is um
when will we be able to do it the normal
way
well what you're doing now bill is one
of the normal ways having sexual
intercourse is just one of the ways
people communicate sexually
couples who are able to have sexual
intercourse find that it's just one of
the things that they choose to do to
give each other pleasure I'm sure you'll
discover that too
the major event in this session is the
physical examination of both partners
after the wife's General examination the
husband is brought into the examining
room where they both participate in the
anatomy demonstration
fine come on in
after Bill and Burl entered the room
bill is invited to look over my shoulder
I give sue a mirror
which she can hold and with Bill observe
the demonstration of anatomy and
explanation of the vaginismus phenomenon
wow I
might be where it was or what was uh you
know in it well for me it was always hit
and miss
I didn't know either you didn't no but
you're a nurse ha how is I supposed to
know they never taught us about it
and I wasn't even supposed to touch it
and I certainly couldn't see it after
all I'm not that good in acrobat now you
both know that you're physically normal
Bill your penis is quite normal and sue
your vulva and your vagina are quite
healthy and quite adequate
then why why do I tighten up like that
and um
why can't he
put it in
watch Sue
that was a perfectly normal reaction to
fear
when Burl overcomes her fear of my hand
see she doesn't blink
during Sue's examination she was given a
small lubricated dilator to insert in
her vagina she will proceed through a
set of graduated vaginal dilators at her
own pace she's also been instructed to
insert her finger into the vagina to
have some idea where it is and how it
feels together the Williams are
instructed in the principle of
pleasuring as outlined by Masters and
Johnson while it's now about four days
later the Williams are back we've
already learned that Sue's been able to
insert the smaller dilators and has even
been able to put the tip of her finger
in her vagina
bill
what have you learned from pleasuring
each other
well once I got over being embarrassed
you know I really enjoyed watching Sue
and I like the chance giving pleasure to
Bill really giving
not just lying there and letting him do
everything
yeah only one thing still bothers me say
it Belle
I still
um kind of um
come fast
I can see how that would concern you
Bill
we'll deal with that area we've dealt
with other areas and made progress in
them and we'll make progress in that
area too I it'll be clear if we
if we just cycle just what happens
and from that we'll be able to see how
the fear of pain and the fear of failure
affect the response okay
let's just take a look at this graph
last time they learned the anatomy of
the sexual organs and this time they
learned the physiology of human sexual
response by explaining the effects of
feelings on the response curve we can
demonstrate how the fear of failure
leads to failure this reinforces our
earlier diagnosis and relates it to the
therapy the point of no return prior to
ejaculation is noted on the graph and
related to The Squeeze technique for
learning ejaculatory control
in this session we encourage Sue to
continue inserting the dilators her
finger and later Bill's finger into the
vagina together they will practice The
Squeeze technique to help them deal with
Bill's ejaculatory control
it's now a week later and time for our
next session with the Williams right and
Sue's looking fine but Bill's a bit
unhappy tell us about it sue well I'm
doing just fine I can insert those
dilators and I could even get my finger
in
but um where'd you get stuck Bill well
well
when I came close to her with my finger
I have a spasm and it made me feel just
like a failure back to the old business
you know right back where I started oh
that's not true bill you're a lot better
your erection lasts a lot longer before
your ejaculation Hey listen to the
language I'm using
I hear Sue saying that she's real
pleased with you Bill and I'm real
pleased with you too that's real great
you're both doing well it's predictable
Sue that at this stage anything that you
didn't insert in the vagina would cause
spasm The Next Step will be for you to
insert Bill's finger into the vagina in
the same way as you've become
comfortable with inserting those
dilators
in this session the Williams were given
further reassurance and encouragement in
addition to the earlier tasks bill would
insert his finger in the vagina first
under Sue's control later on his own and
eventually during sex play
I'd like to make a special comment
it is important to understand the
purpose of these tasks they are just a
framework for the real learning
experience this consists of constant
feedback of feelings to each other the
knowledge of their partner's feelings
makes them confident that what they are
doing is effective it protects them from
turning their partner off and feeling
like a failure
let's see the next session is the fourth
session with the Williams right and
they've reported real progress and Seuss
found great pleasure in her ability to
stimulate bill
isn't that right Sue
that's right I never thought it would
happen but I like seeing him
you know react
no kidding
um I mean I I've always enjoyed watching
Sue but I didn't know you liked it too
well you really turned me on geez
how about that
it's important to tell your partner when
you're pleased and when you're not
pleased isn't that right bro well I'm
real pleased with you right now Noam you
said that very well well thanks very
much
this was the last of the sessions that
we had contracted for with the Williams
but they didn't feel ready to terminate
the therapy just yet we agreed to see
them again for two more sessions during
the next month Bill and Sue were
instructed to continue the tasks
outlined earlier in addition Sue would
use his penis to caress her vulva and
eventually her vagina
the Williams were seen two weeks later
both very pleased they saw no further
need for sessions we asked them to come
in for a follow-up in two months and
stress to them the importance of
maintaining the effective pattern of
communication they had learned we warned
them that there would be ups and downs
and invited them to contact us if they
really felt stuck
quite a difference isn't there
well it's just great and we're trying
some pretty new things now
bill has some pretty wild ideas hey look
look who's talking guess who it was last
night who uh no
uh what is it
hey you're Belle not gnome oh darn it
yeah uh sorry gnome
that's okay Bill
what is it Stan
you've got about one more minute to wrap
this up okay bro do you want to start
the wrap up sure when the Williams first
came to see us they were very depressed
caught up in two Vicious Cycles by
working with a male and female
co-therapy team they have found out that
it's quite possible for people to talk
comfortably with each other about sex by
sharing their feelings they come closer
together instead of withdrawing into the
loneliness they were experiencing when
we first saw them
that's it let's print it